today I invited a chairman of the local
council in Aleppo to personally address
the leaders so that the voice of the
people of Aleppo is heard at least in
this symbolic way will exert pressure on
other global players who are present in
Syria using all available diplomatic
channels
the aim is clear the immediate opening
of humanitarian corridors to allow 8
into Aleppo and for civilians to be
evacuated safely under neutral
international supervision the protection
of civilians is the absolute priority
another point on the agenda was
migration high representative mogherini
reported progress with African countries
for example our partnership with share
is reducing the numbers of people using
smugglers to get to Libya after regards
Ukraine we did what we could to help
save the association agreement that had
already been ratified by 27 member
states and the European Parliament we
have adopted the legally binding
decision of the leaders to facilitate
the ratification in the Netherlands this
decision addresses all the concerns
expressed by the Dutch voters earlier
this year now the responsibility lies
with the Netherlands
moving on to want to break siege the
Euro 27 had a short informal meeting
where we finalized procedural
arrangements and reconfirmed our
principles
meaning the indivisibility of the four
freedoms the balance of rights and
obligations and the rule no negotiations
without notification